what do you think is the meaning of this
whole thing what's the meaning of life
self-respect
that's a fast answer there's a story
behind it if you want the story i would
love to have the story there's a covert
training base in alabama
and since south and far south and like
the armpit of america where elite tier
one operators go to learn
human intelligence stuff
and there's a bar inside this base and
on the wall
is
just uh it's scribbles of
uh opinions and the question in the
middle of the wall says what's the
meaning of life and all these elite
operators over the last 25 or 30 years
they all go they get drunk and they
scribble their answer and they circle it
with a sharpie right love
family america freedom right whatever
and then they're the only thing they
have to do is if they're going to write
something on there they have to connect
it with something else on the wall at
least one other thing so if they write
love they can't just leave it floating
there they have to write love in a
little bubble and connect it to
something else connect it to family
whatever else when you look at that wall
the word self-respect is on the wall and
it's got a circle around it and then you
can't see any other word because of all
the things that connect to self-respect
just dozens of people have written over
have written their words down and been
drawn and scribbled over because of all
the lines that connected self-respect so
what's the meaning of life
from my point of view i've never seen a
better answer
it's all self-respect if you don't
respect yourself how can you do anything
else how can you love someone else if
you don't have self-respect how can you
build the business you're proud of if
you don't have self-respect how can you
raise kids how can you make a difference
how can you pioneer anything how can you
just wake up and have a good day
if you don't have self-respect
the power of the individual that's what
uh
that's what makes this country great i
have to say after traveling quite a bit
in europe and especially in in a place
of war
um coming back to the united states
makes me really appreciate about the the
the better angels of this nation the
ideals it stands for the values it
stands for and i'd like to thank you for
serving
this nation for time and humanity for
time and
for being brave enough and bold enough
to still talk about it and to inspire
others to educate others for having
many amazing conversations and for
honoring me by having this conversation
today you're you're an amazing human
thanks so much for talking today lex i
appreciate the invite man it was a joy
you